[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités une
émission pour découvrir celles et ceux
qui font l'actualité du département est
aujourd'hui parole à theillay de
ferradji le responsable de l'un des
pôles le pédo psychiatrique du centre
hospitalier jean-martin-charcot de saint
cyr l'école
un pôle qui a de nouveaux locaux dans
ses mines et dans cette émission vous
entendrez aussi hervé le treut
climatologue français
alors qui est organisée ce jeudi l
observatoire de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
une conférence autour des impacts causés
par le changement climatique
non on débute donc cette émission avec
vous tayeb ferradji bonsoir l'anchois
alors vous êtes je le disais le
responsable dé la deûle un dépôt le pédo
psychiatrique du centre hospitalier de
saint cyr l'école et vous avez donc de
nouveaux locaux qui ont été inaugurée le
12 décembre fait pas d'erreur jusque là
non c'est parfait dites-nous déjà ses
premiers pas dans ses nouveaux locaux
comment ça se passe il m'a écouté c'est
parfait on est très contents les
professionnels sont très contents parce
que des nouveaux locaux
zazie puis une formule adaptée plus
spacieux plus confortable mieux chauffer
en cette période d'hiver
donc les enfants et les familles sont
mieux accueillis dans de meilleures
conditions
donc on ne peut être que satisfait quand
on arrive à améliorer la qualité des
prestations qui sont un service public
donc c'est au service des enfants et de
leurs parents
vous parlez des prestations ces nouveaux
locaux c'est aussi pour proposer des
nouvelles prestations de nouvelles
activités ce que vous pouvez nous en
parler
vous savez
on est si je puis dire un peu en période
de vaches maigres donc pour développer
de nouvelles activités
c'est très difficile d'avoir de nouveaux
financements donc on essaye d'innover
donc de restructurer de transformer un
certain nombre de choses donc c'est
trois unités qui ont été inaugurés le 12
deux de ses unités une unité a été
relocalisée parce qu'elle était à bois
d'arcy dans des locaux j'ai envie de
dire impropre l'accueil des enfants
surtout qu'elle accueillit de la femme
peu importe à l'accueil des petits
enfants de 2 à 5 ans a alors que
maintenant va désormais ils vont être
accueillis à s'insère dans de
magnifiques locaux qui ont été aménagés
qui sont spacieux qui sont comme je le
disais confortable donc tout le monde
est très content et puis surtout ça
rapproche les professionnels du lieu où
est basée l'équipe parce qu'avant il y
avait des déplacements les
professionnels étaient sales c'était
c'était quand même plus difficile à
présent se réunit à saint cyr et c'était
l'objectif
les deux autres unités sont nouvelles
mais elles sont nées de restructuration
d'anciennes activités l'une de ses
nouvelles et paul excuses en activité
c'est le seul hôpital de jour c'est ça
c'est un hôpital de jour qui est
spécialisée dans l'accueil des enfants
autistes et qui justement je vais vous
demander à qui est il dessine et qu'est
ce que vous proposez dans ce dans cette
unité comme comme activités pour les
enfants et bien écoutez je vous remercie
de me le demandez pas ce que c'est
l'occasion pour moi de dire ici devant
vous que je suis très content des
professionnels qui travaillent parce
qu'en fait ils ont ils ont anticipé les
directives des tutelles et de la haute
autorité de santé en matière de prise en
charge de l'autisme
parce que il propose des prises en
charges qui ce qui se cale qui se colle
au plus près des recommandations
actuelles en matière de prise en charge
en incluant les parents les familles
aussi bien au sein de la structure qu'on
allons à domicile faire un travail
d'accompagnement de prise en charge des
enfants autistes afin de 2
de faire advenir des parents à une
position de vrais partenaires et qu'ils
soient partie prenante et que ce qui se
fait à l'intérieur du service ne soit
pas une parenthèse et qu'ils puissent
continuer à domicile dans votre service
vous avez aussi un jardin d'enfants
thérapeutique est ce que vous pouvez
nous en parler nous dire en quoi ça
consiste là aussi avec jardin d'enfants
thérapeutique justement c'est la
structure qui a déménagé de bois d'arcy
à saint cyr l'école et c'est une
structure qui est destiné aux enfants
qui ont entre 2 et 5 ans et chez
lesquels on soupçonne ce qu'on appelle
des traits autistiques donc qui viennent
ils sont en observation ça permet
d'affiner le diagnostic ça permet de de
préparer une orientation de faire de
l'éducation thérapeutique et et de
mettre en place des prises en charge
dans une logique de sur mesure parce que
chaque enfant est différent
là ce sont des consultations pour les
enfants uniquement mais il ya une
troisième unité là c'est pour les
parents et les enfants et les bébés et
les bébés et c est moi c'est l'unité
parents-bébé colibri donc donc
effectivement c'est une unité qui est
qui est composé d'un hôpital de jour ou
les bébés et leurs parents peuvent être
accueillis pour une hospitalisation de
jour c'est à dire de 9h à 17h
mais qui a aussi une partie qui
composait d'une équipe mobile de
périnatalité qui peut se déplacer dans
les maternités au domicile dans les pmi
et dans d'autres lieux où on en est
sollicité pour des problématiques qui
concernent les questions périnatale donc
c'est vraiment ça le brasse tout le
champ de la périnatalité
une dernière question combien d'enfants
et de parents sur l'ensemble de ces
trois unités vous pouvez accueillir
alors c'est forcément un chiffre à la
louche
donc parce que vous savez il ya on parle
dans notre jargon il ya le terme de file
active c'est à dire c'est le nombre
d'enfants qui sont aux vues pendant une
année
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre et en
termes de file active pour ces trois
unités on est à plusieurs centaines
après il ya ceux qui sont pris en charge
chaque jour
hélas ces quelques dizaines tous les
jours merci docteur ferradji pour toutes
ces précisions
on continue ce set 8 invités avec une
conférence sur le climat baptisé
changement climatique impacts et
adaptation qui est programmée ce jeudi à
15 décembre à partir de 18h30 à
l'observatoire de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines implantée à
guyancourt décryptage de cette soirée
avec un autre journaliste michael et
demi d'euros il a interrogé rencontrer
le célèbre climatologue français hervé
le treut de nous sommes allouées skull
observateurs de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines c'est ici que se déroulera
le jeudi à 15 décembre à 18h30 la
conférence baptisée changement
climatique impacts et adaptation pour
nous parler de cet événement
hervé le treut tu professeur université
pierre et marie curie climatologues
français et professeur à l'école
polytechnique qui sera d'ailleurs
l'invité d'honneur de la soirée bonjour
bonjour alors pourquoi organiser un tel
événement ici à saint quentin en
yvelines
ici on est dans un lieu universitaire
puisque l'on est dans mercy versailles
saint quentin qui est une composante de
l'université paris saclay et on a un
bâtiment qui est dédié en fait à la
recherche sur le climat
d'autres lieux dans la région parisienne
mais celui là est essentiel pour tous ce
qu'est observations du système
climatique et donc c'est tout à fait
naturel de venir parler de climat ici
pouvez vous nous présenter cette soirée
ce sera une soirée exceptionnelle
donc on va effectivement avoir
l'occasion de parler de ces problèmes
dans un moment qui est un moment un peu
particulier puisque là
astuce t il ya très peu de temps il ya
un mois la ratification et la mise en
oeuvre du traité de paris qui avait été
définie l'année précédente lors de la
cop 21 à paris donc on rentre dans une
phase qui est nouvelle pour nos sciences
de dire celle de la diagnostiquer qui
est acceptée par la plupart des des gens
et par la totalité des pays qui a
ratifié maintenant par une majorité de
ces pays avec devant nous réaliser des
les actions qui sont très très lourde en
fait les barras et du charbon du pétrole
du gaz naturel dans un délai de 5 6 10 m
un peu moins deux ans avant la fin de ce
siècle donc dans un délai quand même
très rapide et de ce point de vue là la
science a un rôle qui devient un petit
peu différent aujourd'hui qu'elle et qui
est d'orienter non seulement des alertes
mais maintenant des choix de solutions
et des choix de solutions dans un
dans un cadre où le problème climatique
pose des risques qui sont différents des
risques sociaux des risques d'autres
problèmes environnementaux comme la
biodiversité
donc on est dans un cadre où on va
devoir débattre trancher des problèmes
avec la participation enfin mille
scientifiques doivent jouer un rôle
d'éclairage de ses choix
l'idée de cette conférence est de faire
peur aux personnes qui seront présents
ce jour là où justement proposer des
solutions
donc je crois que la peur est toujours
très mauvaise conseillère et que le but
n'est surtout pas de faire peur mais de
faire prendre conscience et c'est bien
de faire ce à l'échelle des territoires
parce que montrer que ce sont pas des
problèmes qui sont des problèmes
seulement à l'échelle de l'humanité sur
les problèmes qui sont partagées par
dans l'humanité parce que l'atmosphère
réparti les gaz à effet de serre sur la
planète
et comment va se dérouler cette
conférence comment ça va se dérouler il
à avoir une présentation ensuite un
débat avec le public
l'idée de toutes ces conférences au
changement climatique c'est
effectivement de donner des informations
donc il faut faire partie magistrale on
essaie de la faire moins pesant tôt
possible et puis après de laisser venir
les questions on a on est sur des sujets
où les scientifiques ont besoin d'être
interrogé par grand public la société
civile ont
on n'est pas seulement en train de faire
la morale par rapport à tout ça il ya
des problèmes qui sont des problèmes
liés au changement climatique qui
doivent effectivement est exprimé par
des gens qui viennent donc en oui on
attend cette phase de débat à la fin
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que les gens
retiennent cette conférence mâconnais
face à un problème qui est important et
mais qu' on est aussi fasse un problème
qu'il faudra bien sûr se confrontaient
donc il faudra chercher des solutions
seront meilleurs moins bonne mais il
faudra s'y qu'il faut à s'y confronter
et il faut se préparer à cette
confrontation là c'est pas il ya une
certaine complexité des choix qui sont
devant nous certaines marges aussi de
faire des choix différents
donc il faut que la la société civile
soit au rendez vous de ces décisions là
donc c'est un petit peu de ce message
qui est aussi un message d'appel à une
certaine prise de conscience elle c'est
une éducation plus large ces problèmes
qu'on essaiera transmettre avec un ou
trois les trois orateurs
est ce qu'il y à une deadline pour la
terre disons que les il n'y a pas de
deadline au sens où lorsqu'on on
atteindrait un point terminal dans
autour mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
plus on laisse les choses se développer
plus on aura des conséquences
importantes
et de ce point de vue là il n'y a pas de
vraiment des faits de feuilles au sens
où on entend quelques fois c'est à dire
un moment où si on a dépassé le seuil on
peut plus rien faire et puis c'est plus
la peine non ça vaut toujours la peine
parce que on peut toujours avoir pire et
il vaut mieux prendre toutes les mesures
qu'on peut pour effet que ce soit il n'y
a pas donc une date limite
je pense qu'ils
il faut pas attendre puisque on engage
le futur avec des émissions qui se
stockent dans la bête n'ose faire sur
des durées très grande
donc il faut pas il ya poil système de
non retour une fois qu'on a mis ces
choses dans l'atmosphère ces gaz dans
l'atmosphère ils vont agir pendant très
longtemps donc il faut pas les mettre
ensuite on n'est pas effectivement dans
un mode où on peut devenir complètement
passifs à partir d'un certain plan se
dit maintenant c'est fini on s'en va on
en est pas là merci beaucoup et hervé le
treut tu je le rappelle la conférence
sur le climat est programmée le jeudi 15
décembre à 18h30
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
nouvelle édition demain même heure en
attendant retrouvez toutes nos séquences
sur tv fil 78 points comme bonne soirée
à tous
[Musique]